.
Alexandre Duval.- Les cheminéese
Horne sont loin d'émettre
seulement de l'arsenic
dans l'air de Rouyn-Noranda.
En réalité, selon les plus
l'entreprise rejette au moins
23 contaminants; du cadmium,
nickel, du plomb, par exemple.
Et pour plusieurs de ces
substances, la fonderie est le
plus grand pollueur au Québec,
MARYSE BOUCHARD, prof., Dép.,
de santé et environnement, UdeMM
- C'est urgent selon l'analyse
que j'en fais. Ce n'est pas
qui perdure depuis de nombreuses
années qu'on devrau'on devrau'oe
l'accepter.
- Cette spécialiste juge
la liste inquiétante.
D'autant plus que la science
déterminer précisément l'effet
combiné de ces substances
sur la santé humaine, dit-elle.
- Il y a plusieurs substanceène,
grande inquiétude, donc,
aussi dans cette liste-là
plusieurs métaux, contaminancons
qui peuvent avoir un effet sur
le cerveau, qui sont des
neurotoxiques. Et ça, çam'inquie
sont des effets souvent qui vont
donner... un peuient pas à l'oe.
Horne soutient que pourcertaine,
dont l'arsenic : "Les données
d'une contamination de la sonde
utilisée à l'usine l'année
dernière."
de cancer du poumon à Rouyn-
Noranda sont désormais bien
documentés. Et le gouvernement
selon la députée locale.
ÉMILISE LESSARD-THERRIEN députée
QS Rouyn-Noranda - Témiscamingue
interpellation en février
dernier sur la question de
la qualité de l'air avec le
ministre questions : est-ce
qu'ils ont des données pour
savoir c'est quoi les effets
synergiques d'une exposition à
plusieurEt le miEt le miEt le me
de me répondre.
- Le ministre de l'Environnement
Benoit Charette négocie
Horne pour la forcer à réduire
ses émissions d'arsenic.
Mais devant la longue liste
de contaminants, il se dit aussi
pour d'autres métaux,
comme le réclament
de plus en plus d'acteurs,
dont la députée locale et